اشترك
[موسيقى]
اشترك نعم مرحبا
لقد وصل صغاري المحبوبون
العروس ذات الطابقين عندما تدخل العروس
داخل
مرحبا اهلا وسهلا
أهلا بك؟
هذا لا يستحق
في هذه الحالة
ولا شيء
لقد ألقى بالفعل بعدنا
لأنني بالخارج
فكيف كان يومك يا كهرباء
أريد الكثير بالفعل يعتمد عليك
تضع شيئا
في هذه الوظيفة
إنه يستحق كل هذا العناء لم نشجع حتى أراك
تفصل الثواني أسبوع
نعم الان
ماذا
و الآن
أصبح الأطفال الصغار جدًا أكثر من ذلك بكثير
عائلة ذهبنا إليها كانت
ماذا سأقول لملايين التجار و
قرن بدون كهرباء
كل ما عاشوه في تركيا
في الواقع ، لقد رأيته في جميع أنحاء العالم في تركيا.
كان الأمر هكذا في العادة في الأعلى في الصحف الصغيرة
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي والإسراع
يتلاشى لكنه
14 مليون مشترك ما يقرب من 4 ملايين
حاول أن تجعل صوت المشترك مسموعا
نعم الكهرباء واسعة
أتساءل كيف قطعت عائلة
أعمل في هؤلاء الأطفال يذهب الأطفال إلى المدرسة
نحن نذهب لملابس الأطفال
اشترك